y la función f está definida sobre los
números reales esta tabla de valores
seleccionados df aquí tenemos la tabla
en donde para cada valor de x nos
muestran el valor correspondiente de fx
cuál es una estimación razonable para el
límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a 1
desde la izquierda entonces pause en el
vídeo y vean si pueden resolverlo
ustedes son los primeros ok vamos a
resolverlo juntos primero es muy
importante que nos demos cuenta de que
estamos buscando el límite cuando x se
aproxima a 1 y después tenemos este
super índice negativo esto no significa
que se aproxima a menos 1 esto no
significa menos 1 muchas veces nuestro
cerebro ve uno y luego ve ese signo
negativo y lo interpreta como una forma
extraña de escribir menos uno incluso a
veces ni lo pensamos pero no es eso aquí
se refiere al límite
de fx cuando x se aproxima a 1 desde la
izquierda
y como sabemos eso bueno porque eso es
lo que nos dice ese pequeño signo
negativo nos indica que nos aproximamos
a uno desde valores menores a uno pero
si nos aproximamos desde la derecha
entonces serían valores mayores a 1 y
este signo sería positivo entonces vamos
a ver buscamos el límite cuando x se
aproxima a 1 desde la izquierda y
afortunadamente para nosotros en esta
tabla tenemos algunos valores de x que
se aproximan a 1 desde la izquierda aquí
tenemos 0.9 que es muy cercano a 1 y
después nos acercamos aún más y observen
que todos estos valores son menores a 1
pero se aproximan cada vez más a uno
entonces lo que en realidad queremos
analizar es cuál es la aproximación de
fx cuando x se aproxima más y más a uno
desde la izquierda y bueno la clave para
esto es que si pensamos en los límites
no solamente el límite
de una dirección nos fijaremos por la
izquierda y por la derecha pero aquí nos
piden únicamente el límite por la
izquierda así que solamente analizaremos
estos valores y de hecho no deberíamos
dejar que el valor de fx en x igual a 1
nos confunda muchas veces el límite se
aproxima desde un valor diferente al
valor de la función en este punto
entonces vamos a ver en 0.9 f x es 2.5 y
cuando nos acercamos más desde la
izquierda tenemos 2.1 y al acercarnos
más a 1 desde la izquierda nos acercamos
aún más a 2 así que una estimación
razonable para el límite de fx cuando x
se aproxima a 1 desde la izquierda sería
2 parece ser que fx se aproxima a 2
aunque no lo sabemos con exactitud por
eso nos preguntan cuál es una estimación
razonable porque puede ser que nos
aproximemos a 2.01
a 1.999 y generalmente en khan academy
este tipo de preguntas serían de opción
múltiple en las que tienen que elegir la
que sea más razonable pero si decimos
bueno si tal vez esto se aproxima a todo
el número entonces tal vez dos sería una
estimación razonable aunque no
necesariamente tiene que ser dos podría
ser 2.0 1258 pero al parecer aquí hay
una estimación razonable para el límite
conforme nos aproximamos a este valor
desde la izquierda veamos otro ejemplo
ahora nos dicen que la función f está
definida sobre los números reales y esta
tabla nos da valores seleccionados de
efe muy parecido al ejemplo anterior
cuál es una estimación razonable para el
límite cuando x se aproxima a menos 2
desde la izquierda
bueno aquí es un poco confuso ver dos
signos negativos el primer signo nos
indica que nos aproximamos a menos dos
así que veremos qué pasa
y nos acercamos a menos dos y el segundo
nos indica que nos aproximamos
nuevamente desde la izquierda y bueno
afortunadamente para nosotros nos dan
algunos valores de x que se aproximan a
menos 2 desde la izquierda entonces esto
es cuando x se aproxima a menos 2 desde
la izquierda y eso es justo lo que
tenemos aquí porque miren esto es menos
2.05 y después nos acercamos más con
menos 2.0 1 y después todavía más con
menos 2.002 y todos estos valores son
menores a menos 2 por eso es que nos
acercamos cada vez más a menos 2 pero
vamos a ver cuando nos encontramos un
poco más lejos
fd x es menos 20 y cuando nos acercamos
más es menos 100 pero al acercarnos
todavía más es menos 500 así que parece
razonable aunque no lo podamos saber con
exactitud porque éstos sólo son algunos
puntos muestra para esta función pero si
seguimos
la tendencia conforme nos acercamos más
y más a -2 sin llegar a ese valor
parece que la función es no a contable
es decir que se vuelve infinitamente
negativa así que técnicamente esto es
infinito entonces si esta pregunta fuera
de opción múltiple podríamos decir que
el límite cuando x se aproxima a menos 2
desde la izquierda no existe no existe
pero si alguien nos hiciera la otra
pregunta es decir si nos dijeran cuál es
el límite de fx cuando x se aproxima a
menos 2 desde la derecha bueno podríamos
decir que aquí los valores se aproximan
a menos 2 desde la derecha por lo tanto
esto es x cuando se aproxima a menos 2
desde la derecha y recuerden que cuando
tenemos un límite muchas veces podemos
distraernos al observar el valor actual
de la función en ese punto en particular
por eso queremos pensar en cuál es el
valor de la función cuando x se aproxima
a ese valor en este caso cuando x se
aproxima a menos 2 desde la derecha
entonces conforme nos acercamos más y
más a menos 2 desde valores mayores a
menos 2 podemos ver que nos acercamos
cada vez más a menos 4 que de hecho es
el valor cuando x es igual a menos 2 así
que es una estimación razonable y bueno
en este caso si nos aproximamos a
diferentes valores de zelaya
izquierda podemos decir que en ese punto
el límite de la función no existe y eso
es algo que ya habíamos visto en otros
vídeos